I interviewed this guy recently talking about animal stuff.
He,
uh,
he was doing his phd in University of Pennsylvania and he was working in
psychology,
but there were chimps involved in his research and so they,
like,
they would come into these cages,
but they had this big area outside back behind the cages.
Right.
We're so like at night they would go hang out and there were trees and stuff and
whatever.
So he would hang out until everybody went home and he was alone.
And then he'd sneak back into the area where the chimps were.
And he told this hilarious story where he's with his champion.
He'd let go back there and you know,
smoke a joint at the end of the day.
And the chimps are wondering,
right.
And one day this chimp comes over and sits down next to him and he's smoking a
joint and the chimp reaches,
no,
he has not get this champion.
The joke to the gym.
No,
it just hits it.
It gives it back to,
oh my God,
that,
that would be the greatest video ever on youtube.
But Dude,
get,
there's one of a chimp fucking a frog.
Have you ever seen him at all?
I have is kind of sad.
Yeah.
Not for the chimp,
but,
but one of a chimp smoking joint with a dude.
Especially a hippie.
Right.
Don't be the ultimate.
Don't bog garden man.
And if he did Bogart or what are you going to do?
You know,
give the chimp to joint.
Shut the fuck.
Exactly.
Where rips your arms off.